on en parle avec jamal white king
professeur d'histoire contemporaine et
de relations internationales à
l'université libanaise bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france c'est une manifestation qui
se tient devant à la banque du liban ce
n'est pas la première de ce genre alors
hormis la dévaluation de la livre que
reproche-t-on à la banque du liban
bon on reproche des politiques
financières qui ont dévalué la monnaie
qui ont annulé toutes les subventions
qui peuvent se
supporter les vallées dans la crise
économique
et tous ces politiques étaient pour le
bien et les pour protéger les intérêts
de la classe bourbourgeoise
mercantile financière au liban il ya eu
par le passé un d'autres manifestations
des rassemblements devant le bâtiment
avec parfois des débordements est ce que
cette fois ça risque d'être le cas selon
vous
quand je vois que néfaste à sion ne vont
pas aboutir à des résultats concrets
qui peuvent affecter les politiques du
gouvernement et de la classe politique
parce que il n'ya pas un mouvement
d'opposition bien unifiée pour l'élite
politique dans ce pays et le conflit
peut se transformer en un conflit
confessionnel quand c'était leur talent
dans à plusieurs reprises alors des
manifestations peuvent aboutir à des
résultats
j'espère que l'on comprenne bien ce que
cela signifie dans le quotidien des
libanais comment cette dévaluation de la
livre
elle pèse dans le quotidien dans votre
quotidien
avant
les salaires ne sont plus les mêmes
qu'auparavant par exemple avoir en tant
que professeur je touche aider à peu
près 4000 dollars avant la crise et
maintenant mon salaire n'excède pas les
200 dollars par mois les prix sont bien
élevés parce que tout est
évalué
en relatif du dollar américain alors lé
prix sont les mêmes
avant la crise économique
en tant que dollars mais si on va
les
mesures et en livres libanaises
il y à une inflation les liens des
hausses des prix en livres libanaises et
la majorité de la population ne peut pas
accéder
aux essentiels de la nourriture ou bien
du carburant etc vous avez vous parlé de
tensions confessionnelles au liban
c'est assez récurrent comment expliquez
nous ce lien justement avec la situation
économique catastrophique que connaît le
pays du cèdre
avant
elle et la classe politique a souvent
synge et où bien des billets au conflit
qui économique
des classes politiques en un conflit
confessionnel pour se protéger contre
un mouvement bien unifiée qui peut
représenter les intérêts de la classe
moyenne et des classes ouvrières alors
c'était le cas à plusieurs reprises et
inclut la crise ou bien la guerre civile
qui est a commencé comme une guerre
ou
résultant des classes du conflit de
classe
ouvrière et moyens contre la classe
mercantile bordeaux et bourgeoise en un
conflit confessionnel qui peuvent
diviser la société verticalement entre
groupes confessionnels entre communautés
pour que la classe bourgeoise
aux capitalistes du pays peut diviser la
société pour qu'elle ne se confronte pas
à un mouvement unifié de la sphère des
classes ouvrières
et l'opposition est ce qu'il ya une
vraie finalement opposition capable de
porter la voix du peuple libanais parce
qu'on sait que ce peuple libanais et
prouve une défiance vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la classe politique
dommage que les puissances non
confessionnelles sont très faibles ils
ne sont pas unifiées et ne posent pas
ou ne signifie pas on a un seul franc
contre la classe capitaliste du pays et
la classe politique
en fait et on se présente à une loi
parce qu'il y aurait une solution
bon dans ce pays avant plusieurs années
alors le liban qui compte évidemment sur
l'aide internationale l'aide du fmi en
contrepartie les institutions
internationales attendent des réformes
de grande ampleur dans le pays à ses
niveaux où est-ce qu'on en ait
rapidement je crois qu'il n'y aurait pas
de réforme parce que la classe politique
bien enracinée dans la vie politique
libanaise et corrompu et ne veut pas
réformer le système parce que ses
intérêts sont
endommagés
merci à beaucoup à vous djamel wakim je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine et des
relations internationales à l'université
libanaise merci